[Musique]
la frc a le département de la réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la réunion vous
présente terre d'ici
[Musique]
chacun se presse pour immortaliser
l'instant le temps d'un cliché on fait
en effet ce soir-là le 30e anniversaire
de l'urcoopa l'union réunionnaise des
coopératives agricoles pour ses trente
années ans d'exploitation mais c'est 33
années mois de vie puisque moi une
entreprise non à la création de ces
statues et donc les statuts de cuba
était signé un premier septembre 81 à
saint pierre la fédération des
coopératives ce jour là quelques
pionniers de la coopération agricole
visionnaire déjà jette les bases d'une
nouvelle unité de production d'aliments
pour bétail à cette époque là il y avait
quatre petites coopératives je dirais
puisque c'était pas en croire la
dimension qu'on ait aujourd'hui par la
suite mon la copa l'ouest nous a rejoint
dans le cartable et là où nous sommes
aujourd'hui a lieu que par mon c'est un
terrain qui appartenait à monsieur
défaut qui était président de la coop à
l'ouest à l'époque s'il n'avait pas les
moyens d'apporter en numéraire dont le
capital est le terrain était propre aux
témoins dans le toit table en capital à
eux repas en trois décennies lusine deux
camps bay a bien grandi cette soirée
anniversaire est aussi l'occasion pour
jérôme gautier l'actuel président de
leur co pas de saluer le travail
accompli par ses prédécesseurs
tous les jours leur eau hommage à karl t
chez rim au dos qui sont encore là
loulou nous a quittés mais c'est quand
même des gens en qui j'ai de
l'admiration et
je remercie tous les jours que le modèle
coopératif qu'ils ont pu sillonner
qui ont pu mettre à la réunion un modèle
envié par les autres départements
d'outre-mer et on doit être fier
malheureusement lourds y viennent et
plus avec nos pouvoir admirer tout le
travail qu'ils ont pu réussir c'est à
nouvelle génération de pouvoir faire au
moins par est ce qu ils nous ont laissés
aujourd'hui les deux sites de production
situés au port et à caen b produisent
annuellement 180 mille tonnes d'aliments
pour bétail toutes filières confondues
toutes les matières premières que nous
réceptionnons répondant à un cahier des
charges que nous avons définie nous
mêmes en termes de qualité
nutritionnelle et physique des
différentes matières et ensuite sont
utilisés mélanger entre elles pour
répondre à chacun des stades de
production par exemple pour le poulet
rien que pour les formules poulet nous
avons ouï programmes alimentaires
différents pourraient fondre aux
différents types de poulets produits qui
soient bassecourt tous les blancs pour
les jaunes du coq et c'est donc oui
programmes alimentaires différentes le
goût local le goût créole veut des
viandes qui sont soit plus mature donc
nous avons des programmes alimentaires
adaptés à des croissants 5 kg plus lente
qu'on vient justement de la viande qui
se tient bien un poulet parents qui
poussent en 45 jours qui pop en 35
[Musique]
installée aux plates saint leu yvon berg
s'est lancé depuis 2002 dans l'élevage
de porcs fils d'éleveur lui-même ils
vont apprécier aujourd'hui tous les
progrès réalisés par l'urcoopa dans la
fabrication et la fourniture d'aliments
de qualité pour ses animaux non c'est
beaucoup plus facile on a deux sinon
ça ne facilite la vie au niveau de la
composition de l'aliment aussi avait une
différence à l'époque c'était un aliment
simple si on peut dire ben je sais pas
exactement au niveau de composition mais
on n'a rien aliments pour
[Musique]
les animaux non aliments pour chaque
type d'analysé d'animaux
les truies gestantes une poêlée truire
allaitantes a prôné le premier âge on a
des mots croissance est l'aliment
finition on donne vraiment donné le
besoin au niveau qualité et quantitatifs
jeunes agriculteurs jérémy bégat suivi
depuis 2010 les traces de son père papa
avait déjà un site sur le plateau c'est
un lieu où on a fait le choix de
l'installation pour le montant que je ne
ris cutter et il faut aller chercher un
site pour délocaliser l'élevage en
partie puisque le projet apprécié de
ramener toute l'approché ici et ce qui
avait été demandé pour conforter
l'exploitation ça a été de diversifier
l'activité donc on a choisi le poulet
comme on était au sol et qu'on
maîtrisait déjà pas mal bien leur sol
donc on a voulu continuer là dedans et
poursuivre avec eux des performances
techniques pour améliorer les résultats
des marges et pour améliorer davantage
ses performances d'élevage jérémy peut
compter sur les conseils éclairés d'un
technicien de leurs copains c'est
permettre à l'éleveur enfin d'avoir un
autre regard sur l'élevage ce que
l'éleveur qui l'a tous les jours mais il
ya des choses de qui voit plus donc nous
on est là pour le conseiller au mieux ce
tour
alimentation et puis bien sûr un peu
technique aussi
l'appui des techniciens ça rassure dans
le son sur moi je vois les animaux tous
les jours et le technicien il arriva
qu'un regard extérieur et puis les
choses qu'elle moi je suis habitué du
sablier flash tout de suite à l'oeil et
ça nous permet d'échanger et puis de
d'être réactif sur les différents
problèmes qui paye a grandi
en un aliment la qualité de l'aliment la
présentation de l'aliment est donc comme
fait du croissant s'élancer de la miette
n'a en fait il faut que les poussins
mange correctement et qui est
suffisamment d'aliments frais pour
coordination
temps
[Musique]